[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara halbe guten abend und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
montag die vom sport hat norbert lehmann
eigentor von mir und das sind unsere
wichtigsten themen heute
die korona inzidenz steigt auf 201,1 so
hoch wie nie einige bundesländer
verschärfen die zutritts und test regen
ansturm auf die polnische grenze
hunderte migranten in belarus versuchen
die eben grenze zu überqueren
und lichtblick im aartal vier monate
nach der flutkatastrophe ist ein erster
bauabschnitt wieder befahrbar
die wucht der vierten corona welle
hinterlässt spuren auf den
intensivstationen in bayern sachsen und
thüringen ist die lage besonders
angespannt in bayern sprang die
krankenhaus ampel heute von gelb auf die
höchste alarmstufe rot damit gelten ab
morgen landesweit noch schärfere
beschränkungen bundesweit liegt die
inzidenz heute über 200 und damit so
hoch wie noch nie thomas garcia
zwei tage vor heiligabend gab es den
bisherigen höchstwert
197,6 jetzt ein neuer unschöner rekord
wie kann das sein zumal damals noch
niemand geimpft war jetzt sind es gut 67
prozent vollständig und
85,5 prozent der gefährdeten über 60
jährigen allerdings geht es mit dem
impfen kaum voran zugleich wurde das
virus mit der delta variante noch
ansteckender folge vor allem ungeimpfte
stecken sich seit herbst anfangen wieder
mehr an hier die 18 bis 59 jährigen
geimpfte infizieren sich auch aber
weitaus weniger
vergleichbar sind die entwicklungen bei
den über 60 jährigen
entsprechend kommen auch aus dieser
altersgruppe deutlich mehr ungeimpfte
ins krankenhaus als geimpfte viele
ungeimpfte viele auch die ohne symptome
sind und das virus verbreiten all das
erklärungen für die vielen
neuinfektionen und argumente für
verstärktes im ostern und testen
und wie reagiert die bundesregierung die
amtierende die ihr nur noch
geschäftsführend im amt ist hält sich
zurück die potenziell neue spd grüne und
fdp legte heute einen gemeinsamen
gesetzentwurf über künftige maßnahmen
vor er soll von den fraktionen noch
diese woche in den bundestag eingebracht
werden lockdown soll es nicht mehr geben
aber wieder kostenlose tests ist ramms
hat details die korona lage spitzt sich
zu doch die möglichen ampelkoalition
ehre wollen die sogenannte epidemische
lage nationaler tragweite ende november
auslaufen lassen stattdessen bringen sie
neue gesetzliche leitplanken auf den weg
für die fdp ein notwendiger schritt weg
vom ausnahmezustand aber nicht das ende
aller maßnahmen
niemand hat behauptet dass corona vorbei
sein aber die angemessenen instrumente
die wir noch brauchen die eben
verhältnismäßig sind die sinnvoll sind
und zweckmäßig sind stellen wir auf eine
neue rechtsgrundlage
in der diskussion von spd grünen und fdp
die kostenlosen tests wieder einzuführen
auch eine testpflicht in pflegeheimen
ärzte sollen strikt dazu nach impfungen
informieren und die 3g regel soll am
arbeitsplatz gelten
flächendeckende schließung von schulen
handel oder kultur soll es nicht mehr
geben doch die bundesländer sollen
weiter corona maßnahmen wie masken
tragen anordnen können
sie haben bis zum 24
november noch alle möglichkeiten die die
bestätigung der pandemischen lage
letztlich ihnen gibt aber sie werden
auch möglichkeiten haben in zukunft dann
mit einem dann hoffentlich beschlossenen
infektionsschutzgesetz ausreichend zu
arbeiten nicht einigen konnten sich die
potenziellen koalitionäre auf eine
bundesweite zweig regel die vieles nur
geimpften und genießen gestattet in
pflegeheimen soll strenger getestet
werden eine impfpflicht soll es dort
zunächst nicht geben auch aus sorge dass
dann noch mehr personal springt ich
würde es jedenfalls für dramatisch
reichende lage haben wo jemand sagt
bevor ich mich impfen dass er arbeite
ich lieber nicht mehr und das ist eine
erwägung an der ich jedenfalls nicht
vorbei will aber ich möchte gern dass
wir durch sicherheit haben an diesem
donnerstag sollen die ideen der ampel
bereits in erster lesung im bundestag
beraten werden
theo koll in berlin die pandemie lage
verschafft sich zunehmend aber irgendwie
scheint im moment nicht ganz klar wer
jetzt die verantwortung trägt und
handeln muss die alte regierung oder die
künftige
ja also formal ist die lage klar die
alte bundesregierung ist weiterhin
geschäftsführend dem abend aber
politische verantwortung muss natürlich
auch wahrnehmbar sein und daran mangelt
es gerade wieder angela merkel noch olaf
scholz geben erkennbar die richtung vor
deutschland hat gefühlt nicht zwei
sondern keine corona regierung und auch
das bisher vertraute steuerungselement
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz bei der
kanzlerin dass findet ja nicht mehr
statt und verstärkt damit den eindruck
eines machtvakuums vor allem angesichts
der sich so dramatisch verschlechtern
eine pandemie lage denn die inzidenz ist
höher denn je und auch dass sowohl der
bundesgesundheitsminister als auch die
künftige ampelkoalition jetzt gezielt
die epidemische notlage auslaufen lassen
wollen läuft konträr zur gefühlten
bedrohung
auch wenn damit vielleicht der katalog
der tiefgehenden freiheits eingriffe
verkleinert und gerichtsfeste gemacht
hat zur stunde jedenfalls beraten die
fraktionen die
44 seitige gesetzesänderungen zur
aufhebung der epidemischen notlage die
neuen regeln sollen dann rechtzeitig vor
dem auslaufen der alten als
fünfundzwanzigster november in kraft
getreten sein danke für diese
einschätzung theo koll war das aus
berlin als erstes bundesland hat sachsen
ab heute landesweit zweig eingeführt
heißt nur noch geimpfte und genesene
dürfen in restaurants oder kinos zudem
müssen sich in altenheimen alle
ungeimpften mitarbeiter täglich testen
in bus und bahn gilt ffp zwei masken
pflicht all das soll die ansteckungen
bremsen denn mit fast 500 ist die
ambiance in sachsen die höchste ganz
deutschland gleichzeitig hat das
bundesland mit 57 prozent die niedrigste
impfquote cornelia schiemenz
der dresdner gastronom thomas widmann
befürchtet umsatzeinbußen denn bislang
waren rund 30 prozent seiner gäste
ungeimpft aber getestet ab heute dürfen
die nicht mehr ins lokal es gilt zweig
die stimmung allgemein oder den kollegen
unter den lieferanten ist allerdings
sehr sehr getrübt dass wir haben viele
gespräche geführt jetzt den letzten
tagen sagt immer dass wissen und
da herrscht kein optimismus da wachsen
zieht mit 2g die züge an ich find sie
gerecht weil das
mir als kämpfte sicherheit gibt und die
nicht geimpften werden einfach dadurch
geschützt diejenigen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen haben bestimmt ein
grund und es entsteht eine zwei klassen
gesellschaft und das darf nicht sein die
bisherige politik der landesregierung
gescheitert dann viel eigenverantwortung
gesetzt und auch aus den erfahrungen der
letzten drei welt und wir sehen dass das
so nicht funktioniert es sind die
krankenhäuser im freistaat die längst
alarm schlagen die korona
intensivstation der uniklinik dresden
ist so gut wie vor fast ausschließlich
mit ungeimpften das macht manchmal schon
einfach sprachlos wenn sich die
bürgerinnen und bürger einfach nicht
schützen die die möglichkeiten es gibt
nicht wahrnehmen und daher verläufe
entwickeln die sind hier zu uns führen
und dann gibt es eben wirklich viele
patienten wo man sagt sie müssten ja
nicht liegen wenn sie sich geimpft
hätten die zahlen auf der korona station
werden weiter steigen sachsen stehen
schwere wochen bevor
sachsen bayern und andere länder
verkaufen die korona regeln bundesweit
steigen die zahlen wie kommen wir durch
den winter dazu gibt es gleich nach uns
ein zdf spezial und auch in der zdf-
heute- app finden sie jederzeit alle
aktuellen entwicklungen zum thema corona
in einem live blog
bei der spd steht ein führungswechsel an
in der vergangenheit ist das oft großes
polit-drama erbitterter streit
flügelkämpfe im licht des wahlerfolgs
geht das nun offenbar ganz glatt und
geschmeidig lars klingbeil 43 bisher
generalsekretär soll neuer vorsitzender
werden an der seite von saskia esken
klaus bonsack berichtet mit gerade 43
jahren wird er der jüngste parteichef
sein die in die spd hatte und so sieht
es lars klingbeil auch als seine aufgabe
an neue themenfelder zu besetzen und
junge wähler zu gewinnen natürlich stehe
ich auch für einen generationswechsel
ich bin jemand der die neue junge
generation in der spd verkörpert und
möchte dementsprechend auch eben noch
mal einen stärkeren blickwinkel auf
digital politik auf fragen wie
klimaschutz einbringen das ehrgeizige
ziel ist natürlich erst und jungwähler
zurückzugewinnen die wir bei der
bundestagswahl nicht auf unserer seite
hatten mit 27 zum ersten mal im
bundestag zählt er zu den
konservativeren in der spd mit besten
kontakten aber auch ins linke lager dass
er einem halben dutzend vorsitzenden als
generalsekretär diente zeugt von
anpassungsfähigkeit was den mann hat mit
seiner arbeit als generalsekretär
schon vor meiner zeit hier in diesem
haus den grundstein gelegt für die
erneuerung unserer partei gemeinsam mit
andrea nahles und hat natürlich auch
einen ganz erheblichen anteil an unserem
wahlerfolg klingbeil wird auch dafür
sorgen müssen dass die machtzentren die
die spd als regierungspartei
künftig wohl hat miteinander und nicht
gegeneinander arbeiten dass wir diesen
zusammenhalt den wir bisher geschafft
und gelebt haben zwischen partei
fraktion
regierungsmannschaft aber eben dann auch
mit einem starken kanzleramt so weiter
aufrechterhalten die spd baut ihre
parteiführung um parallel zur
regierungsbildung beides verläuft
erstaunlich leise
an der eu ost grenze zwischen polen und
belarus spitzt sich die lage zu
dort versuchen größere gruppen von
migranten gemeinsam die grenze zu
durchbrechen vor allem in der nähe von
caen schnitzer die eu wirft der
belarussischen regierung vor die
flüchtlinge einreisen zu lassen und
gezielt richtung eu grenze zu drängen
anne brühl berichtet aus polen
deutschland deutschland rufen sie vor
der polnischen grenze drei bis
viertausend menschen sollen es sein
machthaber lukaschenko macht ernst hält
niemanden mehr auf richtung polen
berichtet eu
es ist die neueste eskalation zwischen
den nachbarstaaten wir fordern eine
klarstellung von der belarussischen
seite wir informieren unsere eu und nato
verbündeten darüber weil nur eine
gemeinsame antwort dass lukaschenko
regime und putin der ihn unterstützt
stoppen kann
polen verstärkt seine sicherheitskräfte
12.000 soldaten sind jetzt an der grenze
stationiert in den wäldern aber
verstecken sich immer noch viele
flüchtlinge wer aufgegriffen wird dem
drohen von polnischer seite pusch becks
also zurückweisungen nach belarus
menschenrechtsaktivisten kritisieren
dass das ist eine tragödie an verbrechen
das ist ein verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit
polen hat eine sicherheitszone
eingerichtet
hilfsorganisationen aber auch
journalisten sind darin nicht zugelassen
es gilt der ausnahmezustand
außerplanmäßige treffen telefonate mit
den nachbarländern litauen und lettland
die polnische politik im krisenmodus
wir haben es mit der schwierigsten
situation seit beginn des konflikts an
der grenze zu peru zu tun das nur per
schenkung regime organisiert gruppen von
personen die an die polnische grenze
immer wieder hatte warschau dem nachbarn
hybride kriegsführung vorgeworfen
menschen auf der flucht als druckmittel
zu benutzen
lukaschenko bleibt bei seiner taktik
die evangelische kirche in deutschland
kämpft mit den missbrauchsfällen in den
eigenen reihen ein zentrales thema der
synode in bremen opfer verbände werfen
den protestanten vor nicht energisch
genug aufzuklären die kirche wird nun um
vertrauen aus bremen keine klatsche
nancy jahns beklagt mit 17 jahren von
einem geistlichen in ihrer gemeinde
sexuell missbraucht worden zu sein ihre
anzeige habe offenbar drei jahre in
einer schublade der evangelischen
landeskirche hannover gelegen ich bin
tatsächlich
in die landeskirche nach hannover
gefahren und habe gefragt so was ist
denn jetzt hier eigentlich
und habe sehr gute aussagen bekommen die
der pastor ist schon verstorben deswegen
haben wir das nicht weiter verfolgt und
ich wusste ja nun sehr gute aufgrund
dessen dass ich weiterhin mit der
familie kontakt hatte dass er eben nicht
verstorben ist die evangelische kirche
habe die sexualisierte gewalt in ihren
reihen bisher nicht offensiv genug
aufgeklärt so die kritik bei ihrer
jahrestagung in bremen versucht die
kirchenführung nun verloren gegangenes
vertrauen zurückzugewinnen es geht hier
um grundlegende
vorgänge die die seele von menschen
zerstören verletzten die das leben von
menschen zerstören können und wenn wir
das in dieser deutlichkeit auch klar
machen dann ist meine hoffnung dass das
die beste grundlage dafür ist dass wir
fälle sexualisierter gewalt so weit wie
möglich vermeiden können nennt sie ganz
beklagt dass der geistliche dem sie den
missbrauch vorwirft noch immer im amt
sei die ekd verweis generell auf grenzen
juristische aufklärung gerade bei
verfahren die wo es keinen strafprozess
gab bevor wanja klarheit gebracht hat
sondern wo es lange zurückliegt kann es
in einzelfällen passieren dass leider
potenzielle täter noch weiter im dienst
sind die heute auf der ekd-synode offen
geführte diskussion und die einsetzung
von aufklärungs gremien sieht die kirche
als wichtigen beitrag im kampf gegen
missbrauch
jetzt zu einem kleinen lichtblick im
rheinland-pfälzischen a tat bei der
flutkatastrophe im juli war dort auch
die aartalbahn weitgehend zerstört
worden sieben brücken und 20 kilometer
gleise alles kaputt betroffene mussten
notdürftig mit ersatzbussen klarkommen
doch ab heute ist immerhin ein teil der
insgesamt fast 30 kilometer langen
strecke wieder befahrbar von remagen bis
zum bahnhof ahrweiler julia schröter
über einen guten tag in schwierigen
zeiten
das gedränge auf dem bahnhof in remagen
spricht für sich der tag eins an dem die
aartalbahn wieder rollt wird von der
politik gefeiert seit heute früh sind
die ersten orte im teil wieder per zug
erreichbar für die menschen eine
erleichterung ja zum einen ist es
natürlich wichtig dass die leute wieder
mobil werden da die von a nach b kommen
aber vor allen dingen glaube ich ist
auch so ein jahr an mut macht gegen so
ein emotionales dingend wird weder wird
aufgebaut hier kommen auch viele
touristen hin wird sich im zug auch
alles einfach besser zu erreichen
die wiedereröffnete strecke war in der
flut nacht vergleichsweise wenig
beschädigt worden entsprechend schnell
konnte repariert werden anders die
situation weiter hinten im aatal dort
sind die gleise an vielen stellen völlig
zerstört der wiederaufbau hier ist
aufwendiger soll aber trotzdem möglichst
schnell gehen auf der alten trasse
fragen des hochwasserschutzes werden
erstmal zurückgestellt
wir haben uns jetzt alle gemeinsam der
bund das land die kommunale gemeinschaft
und die bahn dafür entschieden zunächst
den weg der schnellen inbetriebnahme zu
gehen und dann in den nächsten jahren
die anderen fragen zu klären seit der
flut ist in der region
schienenersatzverkehr in betrieb
zumindest ein teil davon fällt nun weg
eine entlastung für die gemeinden denn
busse und busfahrer sind knapp das nun
wieder züge fahren bringt den menschen
im aartal ein stück normalität zurück
und das gefühl es bewegt sich was
nach 20 monaten corona bedingtem ein
reisestopp dürfen touristen und
geschäftsreisende seit heute wieder in
die usa fliegen bedingung eine
vollständige impfung und ein negativer
test der höchstens 72 stunden alt sein
darf der andrang wie hier in frankfurt
am main ist groß die flüge in die usa
sind bei den meisten airlines für tage
ausgebucht us-bürger können bereits seit
juni wieder in die eu reisen
und damit sind wir bei der
fußball-bundesliga norbert der
einspieler gestern ganz besonders und
das nicht nur wegen seiner 1 meter 87
kölns stürmer star anthony modeste er
machte beim 2 2 gegen union berlin beide
tore für den ersten fc und zeigte
anschließend auch noch andere
fähigkeiten hut ab oder besser gesagt
auf
modells trifft doppelt und tanzt mit der
mütze seines trainers viel los in köln
der fc früh in führung modells staubt ab
nach sieben minuten aber die gäste
antworten und führen zur halbzeit reers
sondern mit dem ausgleich in der neunten
minute und krümmel in der nachspielzeit
baum dort mit einem appell an die
eigenen fans ist man sagen wir wollen
uns entwickeln wir wollen unseren
fußball entwickeln und nicht von die
zuschauer können das auch machen ich
habe jetzt nicht ein fußballspiel
gesehen was verdient hatte in
irgendeiner form zu pfeifen die nerven
aller die es mit dem fc halten beruhigt
dann wieder modell sein ausgleich in der
86 minute die fans in köln längst wieder
eingefangen der kopfball von modest das
sahnestück des spiels bejubelt mit einem
verkleidungs jubel in köln passt derzeit
ganz viel
und alle tore und alle partien dieses
elften spieltag sie können sie sich noch
mal ganz in ruhe bei uns anschauen wie
immer online zusammengefasst bei uns auf
zdf heute und in der zdf- heute-
ehrung für das team deutschland bei den
sommerspielen und den paralympics in
japan bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier verlieh heute in berlin das
silberne lorbeerblatt an erfolgreiche
athletinnen und athleten das ist die
höchste sportliche auszeichnung der
bundesrepublik bei olympia hatte
deutschland 37 und bei den paralympics
43 medallien geworden
max verstappen nähert sich seinem ersten
wm titel in der formel 1 beim großen
preis von mexiko gelang dem niederländer
ein traum start der red bull pilot
setzte sich gleich zu beginn vor die
beiden mercedes-piloten an die spitze ja
und diese führung gab ja auch nicht mehr
ab und fuhr gut 16 sekunden vor lewis
hamilton über die ziellinie platz drei
belegte vettels teamkollege sergio perez
sebastian vettel wurde siebter mit
schumacher der schied aus
das was vom sport ein geschenk gerne
entweder nebel oder sonne kaum regen so
beschreibt katja hornuf ritters november
wetter von morgen marietta slomka freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn und wir freuen uns wenn sie
morgen wieder dabei sein mögen danke für
ihr interesse und einen schönen abend
noch auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das unwetter tief über dem
westlichen mittelmeer dreht sich da auch
in den nächsten tagen noch weiter über
nordeuropa ziehen einige tiefs und wir
hier in mitteleuropa bekommen es mit
einer hochdruckbrücke zu tun die
reichten vom atlantik fast bis zum
schwarzen meer und dieses hoch von
westen das konnten wir schon heute
beobachten dass weitete sich nämlich aus
und brachte dem westen und dem süden
doch häufiger mal sonnenschein über den
norden und nordosten dagegen zogen
dichtere wolkenfelder die brach noch
etwas regen mit und mit diesen dichteren
wolken haben wir jetzt auch am abend zu
tun selbst in der nacht kann es hier und
da noch mal ein bisschen regnen
besonders hier in sachsen süden es ist
zum teil darunter bildet sich wieder
nebel und so gibt es ein großes nord süd
gefälle bei den temperaturen im norden
werden bis zu sieben grad erreicht in
dieser nacht minus fünf grad sind es
dagegen am alpenrand und morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen meist bei 7 bis
12 grad in süddeutschland kann es auch
mal kälter bleiben besonders dann wenn
sich niebels erhält das könnte zum
beispiel hier in der donau der fall sein
aber der vormittag beginnt es insgesamt
eher trüb nachmittags kommt dann aber
häufiger die sonne zum vorschein
richtung denen kann es auch mal regnen
und ganz ähnlich geht es auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter guten abend